i am back here with the legendary
iman and iman cosmetics launched in 1994
and we actually have um sharon shooter
on
um uh the program who did the
pull-up for change the hashtag which you
uh participated in we luckily at flower
you know participated in because it's
such an important thing to be a part of
what she's doing and
she has umo beauty and
it was funny because everybody put in
their thing what percentage of women
and black women and and what everybody
had at their companies and yours was
like
100 women 85 black
been doing this for 25 years plus and i
read a story about how you showed up to
a shoot and the makeup artist said like
did you bring your own foundation
because we just
don't have it and was there
several catalysts that got you to launch
iman cosmetics that was so
important necessary and groundbreaking
at that time
uh yes actually because it really
happened at that
photo shoot it was in 1975 it was my
first
photo shoot and it was for american
vogue and i have never worn heels
i've never worn makeup before i arrived
in the united states
uh i was uh you know studying political
science i've never seen fashion
magazines i had no idea that there was
anything called fashion that existed uh
you know uh in the world so at that
photoshoot i walked in
uh and there was another model on the
shoot and she was caucasian and the
makeup
artist asked me and i was by the way i
was then 19 years old
he asked me specifically did you bring
your own foundation
but it wasn't lost on me that he didn't
ask that question to the caucasian girl
so i thought something because i had no
idea what he was talking about i didn't
even know what foundation was
so then he proceeded to mix and match
some products and put it on my face
and uh and i looked in the mirror and i
looked gray i
s i looked horribly gray in my skin and
so
what saved my career because that was my
first suit
what saved my career was that the
photographs were actually black and
white
and those uh black and whites hide
multitude of sins
interesting uh you know but what i did
was that i made it my
my job to find something that was
suitable for my skin
so i went to all the department stores i
went to woolworth
you're too young to remember oh no of
course i rocked it at world wars 2.
i came out of the womb 10 with a martini
in 1975. so i was new
i love you i love you for that i love
you for that
i did so and i mixed that mixed product
and put it on my face
and i took a a polaroid camera and i
took pictures so i could see how will it
translate
that was the seed that was imp implanted
in my head that i have to take control
of my own image
you know we were talking about we were
talking about language but in
fashion and beauty you know our our
our our power is how we look our
currency is how our images look
so i wanted to make sure that i took
control of that and that i could
put myself at the best forward life
without
you know and i never went to a fashion
shoot without a foundation from then on
and
then when i reach up i retired in 1989
and
i created in 1994 man cosmetics for
women with skin of color and i say skin
of color because before
i started my makeup everybody especially
black would call just women of color
and even now when you think about women
of color you only think about black
women
but i wanted a new language of beauty of
how to
include everybody in that is because
there are filipinos who are as dark as i
am there are puerto ricans who are
you know the same kind of brazilians
were like so the whole world
i was not interested in the ethnicity i
was interested
in the spectrum of colors that the whole
world comes in
well you have been a pioneer in so many
areas and i thank you for finding the
words
and the solves in the beauty industry
for women to empower properly address
and solve what so many women need
you are an icon with an incredible
vision
and soul and pro
proactiveness which i think is the most
insane thing
and by the way speaking of color fun
fact you have a dog named max
yes who has two different colored eyes
like your
beloved the legendary david bowie which
i was reading a book to my children the
other night
about him and i had never known
that he got punched and that was how his
eye
changed color exactly except
max was boned like that my dog was born
like that
so you are supposed to be surrounded in
these beautiful creatures that
look over you and that you love back and
you and your family your husband max
and everything you're doing and you put
out in the world you're such a part of
the majesty of human capacity
and what good people and how they make
their mark
on this planet and i thank you so much
for being here iman
and kicking off this beauty week it
can't be a greater honor
than to do it with you thank you
thank you very much thank you so much